excès à la récession historique de l'an
dernier précipitée par le cos vite
comment se présente 2021 jusqu'ici la
mise sous perfusion d'argent public de
nos économies et à limiter la casse
évidemment les marchés financiers sont
même au zénith mais dans quel état et
l'économie réelle en ce début d'année
allons nous entrer dans le dur de la
crise ces prochains mois on en parle
tout de suite avec l'économiste jacques
sapir bonsoir jacquet bonne année à vous
un puisque voilà c'est le premier édito
écho depuis de 21 et bien jacques on
parle beaucoup du monde d'après
la pandémie qu'elles sauront donc les
conséquences de cette dernière à cette
année elles seront évidemment
extrêmement importante
vous savez pour la france d'abord dont
on voit bien que l'avenir économique ne
s'éclaire rappaz avant cet été pour
l'europe ensuite et qui va prendre avec
cette pandémie et ça on peut le craindre
un retard économique tout à fait
considérable et enfin pour le monde
parce que effectivement on voit que les
équilibres économiques vont bouger de
manière extrêmement importante
alors voyons donc la france jacques de
quoi seront faits les prochains mois
voire les prochaines années stéphanie je
vous mentirais si je disais que les
perspectives sont bonnes à la deuxième
vague de la pandémie est venu ajouter
son poids au fardeau économique que l'on
pouvait d'ailleurs calculé depuis le
moins d'octobre dernier s'est en
particulier ce qu'avait fait le fonds
monétaire international
le deuxième confinement un début d'année
qui risque d'être chaotique encore au
moins jusqu'à la fin du printemps vont
retarder la récupération de l'économie
le fmi avait calculé que l'on
retrouverait le niveau de 2019 au
printemps 2003 à peu de choses près eh
bien il faudra très probablement
atteindre la fin de 2004 voire le début
de 2025
pour atteindre cet objectif alors est-ce
à dire jacques que 2021 va marquer
l'entrée dans le dur de la crise en
france est tout d'abord quel rebond pour
les d'économies oui là c'est fanny vous
avez là encore tout à fait raison on
sait que dans le cours de 2021 les aides
gouvernementales vont progressivement
s'arrêter c'est d'ailleurs tout à fait
normal mais c'est à ce moment là que
nous allons découvrir à quel point le
pays s'est appauvri durant la crise
alors cette approvisionne
appauvrissement excusez moi on peut
chercher à le calculer et si on rapporte
ça en milliards par rapport au pib de
eh bien on voit que les pertes calculé
début octobre donc avant la deuxième
vague se monte déjà à peu près 300
milliards à l'eau
ils ont 2024 avec les conséquences
économiques de la deuxième vague
on pourrait atteindre 2 420 à 650
milliards d'euros autrement dit entre un
sixième et un quart de la valeur du pipe
de 2022 2019 alors avec quelles
conséquences d'actes pour les français
oui si le pays s'appauvrit évidemment
les français vont s'appauvrir
mais certains vont malheureusement ça
peut ouvrir bien plus que d'autres
il ya déjà 10 millions de personnes qui
sont sous le seuil de pauvreté
et on peut penser que cela devrait
augmenter dans les mois qui viennent
deux catégories de français vont être le
plus touché ça ils vont ils font un être
absolument persuadé ce sont d'abord les
salariés à faible qualification est en
prêt
les travailleurs indépendants qui sont
bien entendu les grandes victimes
déconfinement notre pays va mettre des
années à se remettre du choc de la
pandémie et c'est donc en 2021 que l'on
va malheureusement rentrer dans le dur
de la crise alors malgré cela jacques
les marchés boursiers eux exulte mais
dans le détail tout va finalement passer
bien non non assurément stefanik
clairement le décalage entre la sphère
financière et l'économie réelle résulte
des injections de liquidités des banques
centrales
il ya aussi un décalage entre les
secteurs économiques
parmi les plus sinistrées il ya
évidemment les industries aéronautique
et le tourisme vous savez pour les
industries aéronautiques
l'iata l'association internationale du
transport aérien estime que le transport
aérien c'est qu'on s'est contracté des
deux tiers je dis bien les deux tiers en
2020 et qu'en 2021 son activité devrait
n'être encore que grosso modo de 60% par
rapport à ce qu'elle était en 2019 il
faudra donc atteindre de 2024 à 2026
pour retrouver le nombre de passagers
transportés en 2010 9 dans le meilleur
des cas et on voit très bien toutes les
conséquences que cela aura sur des
industries comme airbus mais aussi
évidemment sur les services associés qui
seront et ses conséquences seront très
profonde
inversement
les activités pharmaceutiques mais aussi
les activités qui sont liées à
l'internet comme le e-commerce et les
activités des plateformes de films qui
propose des visites virtuelles de musées
par exemple il ya tout cela ça s'est
fortement développée mais se sont il
faut le savoir aussi des activités qui
crée relativement peu d'emplois c'est
qu'ils ont devra craindre une très forte
montée du chômage dans les mois qui
viennent alors on vous disait aussi
qu'il y aurait des conséquences sur
l'europe
oui oui absolument et on voit bien que
la pandémie
elle accentue aujourd'hui la division
entre deux groupes de pays d'un côté
évidemment les pays de l'europe du nord
en particulier l'allemagne qui résiste
plutôt mieux 20 avec bien entendu leurs
problèmes et d'un autre côté les pays de
l'europe du sud de l'italie l'espagne et
la france dont les problèmes vont
s'aggraver alors ces pays ont déjà payé
très cher la désindustrialisation imposé
par les règles européennes et par les
effets de l'euro ces dernières années et
là on doit bien qu'il faudra un
pivotement de leur stratégie qui va
devoir s'imposer très rapidement
maintenant alors jacques vous avez
également parlé de changements à
l'échelle mondiale oui tout à fait c'est
famille et c'est sans doute le plus
significatif en ce qui concerne le monde
d'après et lakovic 19
on constate que la croissance de la zone
euro et on le voit sur le graphique sera
très inférieure à celle des pays du g7
évidemment mais aussi des autres pays
développés et même très inférieur aux
pays émergents en particulier des pays
émergents d'asie dont au premier chef la
chine l'économie du monde d'après la
pandémie s'écrira sans la zone euro sans
l'union européenne et nous verrons aussi
c'est un point important ce accélérer le
déclin américain alors que la chine elle
va s'affirmer comme l'une de puissance
économique mondiale une puissance
central dans l'économie mondiale s'est
très certainement la leçon la plus
importante que l'on peut tirer de la
crise actuelle alors en conclusion
jacques ce sont donc des perspectives
plutôt sombres pour nous européens et
pour les français en particulier et oui
c'était là cela s'est fini les
ratés au démarrage de la campagne de
vaccination en france sont de ce point
de vue là très symptomatique
mais il faut savoir que même si cette
campagne a été correctement géré même si
elle avait bien démarré on ne doit pas
s'attendre à des effets significatifs
sur l'économie je voulais dire avant le
début de l'été 2021 et d'ici là
évidemment eh bien les problèmes vont
s'aggraver
la france et plus globalement les pays
de l'union européenne et la zone euro
sont englués dans des politiques
économiques qui se révèle aujourd'hui
avec la crise de lakovic 19 absolument
suicidaire il le paye très cher et il
risque de le payer encore plus cher dans
les mois qui viennent et bien jacques
merci merci on va dire mais bon on a pas
très réjouissant en tout cas ces
nouvelles et à la semaine prochaine avec
on l'espère quand même de meilleures
nouvelles jacques